oh man is our boy back is he back is he
is he ever or did he ever go away really
he never left he's got a fly new music
video for himself he's a dope
it's dope dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
why are you laughing i love christmas i
love him though he's the best
he's not holding them right they're
clearly toy guns
he can barely lift him anyway this whole
thing is great
well he goes hard in the paint though
yeah i know he does that's what i heard
let me
here we go good it's always good to
uh only have your video it is only on
facebook and i'm like come on man
i know it is because if it was on
youtube you'd have found it yes i would
have
you're obsessed with not playing videos
on twitter or facebook like no they're
the [ __ ] worst
i don't even know
wow this is terrible um
so what i'm gathering in this song so
far
is that there is a dough to be acquired
and uh chris b will be damned if he's
not going to uh
to get it apparently this they did say
it's on
it is on his youtube channel here
because if it is
i'm sorry but i can't deal with facebook
uh alexander says are all those awful
tattoos real as real as his money
dog
i don't think the money's real well
that's your being a jerk
oh yeah here it is he said the money's
real i'm gonna take him with his work
i don't even know
freezer
this guy you know it must be nice to be
able to wrap this good and just throw
money out and stuff
like having that kind of life sounds
pretty awesome i would give anything to
have chris b's life
just crushing it yeah killing it um
those are clearly real guns mike and he
better be careful you're gonna make your
tooth crack
are you um are you a pistachio or yes
he's a pistachio are you are you uh
are you a piece of gristle and chicken
you better watch out man you can be
coming at uh uh chris brown that hard
yeah he's not insane in the membrane
that's he's gonna get really mad he's
gonna get really pissed
yeah and he's i know he's gonna go find
some woman who looks like you and beat
her up beat the [ __ ]
you feel good now huh you feel good for
whatever girl kind of looks like either
chris brown's not gonna have to [ __ ]
fracture
somebody keep an eye out for ellen
degeneres
please and you know chris brown probably
could get to ellen
me neither chris me neither what are you
gonna do right
i don't even know uh he's crazy dude
i'm crazy talented
he is crazy dude he'll run up on you
with the strap is that what you want
were they still calling out the strap i
don't know man i guess okay
you know what i don't know if they are
but he is okay that is
he is still calling he still calls it a
trap
[Music]
he is holding that so awkwardly no
that's how you hold a rifle that's not
how you hold it
he almost dropped it twice and then they
left here's the thing right
this is a pre-recorded video so you can
use the footage where you
didn't almost drop the gun three times
you could use that footage
right i don't even know i don't know
anymore
[Music]
maybe you shouldn't have burned it yeah
i mean here's the thing
uh chris and i'm not look i'm no
i'm no like jewy money manager type but
if you don't set all your money on fire
and throw it out car windows then you
don't have to continue to acquire
it at rapid pace you know right like i
know people
um who worked hard and saved up now they
don't even really work
but they also don't throw money into
barbecue grills
he is amazing i'm just looking at his
transcendent you want to see something
so you know how we interviewed him yeah
of course okay
how can i forget recorded it on his end
he recorded it on his end and he posted
it on his page
he's not like art not like us right
there we are man how you doing boys
oh no they're oh no yeah look no no
why wouldn't you just use chris to be
brother
[Laughter]
we would have we would have let you yeah
i don't care you could
have let you rip your hour interview
yeah and put it on your page
like we wouldn't have cared we're in it
so you know what i mean like it would
have been like yeah just go ahead just
put it on your channel um
oh [ __ ] uh
he's just like a darker skinned person
and stuff like that
i will say this dude he's my favorite if
somebody wants to do it he's my favorite
if somebody wants to do it and take our
interview and because this is better
quality than the facebook video
and then put it together like you know
so it looks really high quality
somebody should do that he has a louis
vuitton belt
how much you want to bet he got that at
the flea market
that's a v for that vendetta belt oh god
that's really funny love you chris
you're welcome on the show whenever
obviously you're well just figure out
skype though i'm not doing that facebook
thing again
why not it was fun oh it was [ __ ]
funny all snap yo
it kept popping it was terrible it was
popping and locking dude